قالت بعثه طبيه فرنسيه عادت من غزه ان
الاوضاع الصحيه في القطاع منهاره بشكل شبه
كامل في كل المستشفيات وحذرت البعثه في
بيانها من الوضع الكارثي للمستشفيات
والعاملين بها قالت البعثه التي انتقلت في
مهمه انسانيه الى المستشفى الاوروبي في
القطاع خلال الاسبوعين الاخيرين ان شروط
تقديم الخدمات الصحيه منعدمه تماما ودعت
المنظمات الانسانيه الى التحرك لتقديم
الدعم العاجل لمستشفيات
القطع المستشفى الاوروبي في وضع كارثي
هناك 25 الف شخص حول المستشفى ونحو 4000
داخله يعيشون في الاروقه القصف مستمر وفي
الايام الاخيره وصلت بعض القذائف الى
المستشفى وجزء من السقف نهار يعالج المرضى
على الارض والاصابات كثيره في نفس الوقت
هناك انهيار في النظام الصحي الضمادات
متسخه والقناصه يطلقون النار على مستوى
الراس لدينا الكثير من الجرحى جميع
الاشخاص من المدنيين لم ارى مقاتلا واحدا
من حماس يدخل المستشفى من اجل الحصول على
العلاج